i'm about to share eight very important
truths with you
that we hold to be self-evident one that
the quran
is the truth from god almighty to the
quran
is the last and final revelation sent
down to all of mankind
which contains a successful guidance
towards
life liberty and the pursuit of paradise
three that the quran is literally
the spoken word of god revealed to
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
through
the angel gabriel and that there has
never
been and shall never be any man-made
document likened to its magnificence
and perfection for that the quran has
been preserved
for a miraculous 1400
years and will continue to be preserved
until the end of time because god
almighty has promised this
he has protected the quran all 114
chapters of it never has a single
word or verse been altered
that would god's infallible system
intact the quran
shall remain in all its glory forever
five that the quran is a call to the
oneness of god
whose worship remains for himself only
not to be shared by a son father
mothers nor partner of any kind
that this oneness entails the belief in
his
absolute sovereignty over all of
creation
his befitting attributes and his
deserved worship
that among god's messengers was adam
noah
abraham david ishmael isaac
jesus moses and finally
prophet muhammad peace be upon them all
and that their messages held the same
teachings
and ethics all pointing to the divinity
of god
and a life of worship and morality
six that the quran is not
only a religious doctrine but a guide to
a
total and complete way of life that it
encompasses
all aspects of life from social and
economic issues
to cleanliness and purity of the heart
seven
that the quran and its final message
will remain
the truth forever that if you read the
quran
with an open heart you will see its
magnificence
and miraculous nature for yourself eight
that the message of the quran is islam
and that through this book you will
attain true
liberty and happiness i hope and pray
that this will motivate you to connect
with the quran
thank you for spending a few minutes
with me i really
humbly appreciate it please take one
extra second
to like and share this video along
with doing your best to help the dean
show and reaching our goal
thank you peace be with you assalamu
alaikum